believe me we will wake up in 50 or 100
years and say how did this happen and if
people have a copy of this conversation
they will know how it happened it's
because of cowardice it's because of
apathy it's because of diffusion of
responsibility onto others that these
idea pathogens proliferate if we all
talk against them we will solve the
problem by next weekend
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people it does not get any more
fascinating than the brilliant returning
guest we have for you today he's an
evolutionary psychologist youtuber all
sorts of great things and of course the
author of the parasitic mind gadzad
welcome back oh so good to be with you
guys thank you they call you the
godfather uh it's so great to have you
back on the show and blessing us with
your presence uh tell us last time we
spoke about your book the parasitic mind
which is about how bad ideas idea
pathogens as you call them are
destroying the west it's been about uh
18 months since we last had our
conversation uh have things got better
or worse
uh worse in that uh
justin trudeau got re-elected so then
the the jet the the walking
manifestation of every idea pathogen
covered in the parasitic mind is still
prime minister of canada you can't keep
a good black man down
[Music]
black women exactly
for those of you who don't know the
the the genesis of that joke basically
justin trudeau gets caught in blackface
roughly every 15 minutes
and then of course we have uh joe biden
and kamala harris who are now uh the the
the you know the folks in power in the
united states so
i'm kind of conflicted on the one hand
i'm upset that these realities these
realities exist on the other hand it's
only more good business for my book
because the more you have insane
politicians who are leading the way the
more my book is evergreen
well
we're sort of talking about it in a
light-hearted way but for people who are
maybe coming to to some of your ideas
for the first time just give everybody a
bit of an overview gad when you talk
about idea pathogens and you talk about
the election of joe biden over donald
trump they're like no justin trudeau
re-election of justin trudeau over his
opponents uh you know what what are you
talking about when you say idea
pathogens what do you mean
right so first maybe it's worthwhile
repeating why i use the the metaphor of
parasitic mind right so
uh as an evolutionist one of the things
that uh i do is that i often times when
i'm trying to study a human phenomenon i
then try to look for
uh homologous phenomena in the animal
kingdom and so in this case i wanted to
find a way to
root
the concepts that i was discussing in
the book which i'll talk about in a
second in a uh in an
animal context so in in the animal
kingdom you have many cases of parasites
of course that will infect a host
the sub branch called
neuroparasitology is when the parasite
will end up in a host's brain altering
its circuitry and behavior to suit the
benefits of the parasites so toxoplasma
gandhi uh the mouse that is infected
with it will lose its innate fear of
cats as a matter of fact it will become
attracted to the uh cat's urine which is
not a really good thing for a mouse to
be attracted
so there are many many examples in the
animal kingdom where a host will will
engage in irrational maladaptive
behavior so
i had found the framework that i would
use to then argue well human beings can
be parasitized by actual brain worms
like toxoplasma gandhi but there's
another class of pathogens that can
parasitize our minds and i call those
idea pathogens but they ultimately end
up with the same outcome which is if
you're parasitized by these bad ideas
you no longer can think clearly
you no longer engage in common sense in
reality you engage in irrational
behaviors in the service of the
proliferation of those idea pathogens
now what are examples of these idea
pathogens there are many that i discuss
in the book let's start with probably
the granddaddy of them all postmodernism
is a dreadful idea pathogen because it
is
it is intellectual terrorism it is a
rejection of the epistemology of truth
it basically says there are no objective
truths we are shackled by our personal
biases we are shackled by subjectivity
to therefore talk about some truth is
silly because there is no such truth
well that's perfectly anti-scientific
right because scientists do wake up
every day thinking that there are
natural truths to be discovered of
course in science we have provisional
truths meaning what was true
300 years ago may no longer be true
today but we do operate under the
epistemological premise that there are
truths to be discovered post-modernism
says there is no such thing
maybe i could give you one or two other
pathogens is that yeah yeah go for it
uh so that
intellectually terroristic framework
then allows for a whole subset of other
idea pathogens to proliferate take for
example the idea pathogen of social
constructivism which basically says that
there are no innate biological
blueprints there are no instinctual
imperatives
everything that we are stems from tabula
rasa we're born empty slaves and it's
only our unique socialization that makes
us who we are so if bubba can uh bench
press more weights than
linda it's not because there might be
any morphological anatomical
physiological hormonal differences
between men and women it must be because
he was socialized to play rough and
tumble when he was a kid and linda
wasn't right so we we root everything in
social construction
well that's a lovely message because it
presumes that we are all born with equal
potentiality but it's also a perfectly
nonsensical message so i basically in
the book go through all of these idea
pathogens i demonstrate how they've all
been uh
they've all started they were all
spawned within the university ecosystem
and then towards the end of the book i
offer a vaccine against these uh
ideas uh god let me ask you something i
love the way you you talked about equal
potentiality because i think this is a
lot of of where this may come from which
is
these ideas first as you said you
eradicate the idea that there's a truth
to be found
via post-modernism and then
you furnish people with ideas that make
them feel good because the truth is
often unpleasant we're not all equal
we're not born with equal potentiality
but if you want to feel good about the
world if you want to feel that you know
you are where you are not because of
some inherent failings or disadvantages
that you were simply born with but
rather because society is evil and
oppressive and whatever then these ideas
all make sense so how much of this is
simply about creating a framework where
you can get ideas in that just sound and
make us feel really good about ourselves
so it's partly that and it's also so so
let me back up and answer your question
in a much broader way when i was trying
to look for commonalities across these
idea pathogens
i thought okay well each of these
pathogens
has a different structure to it but is
there any commonality so then i again
went to analogize with cancer in this
case
if you look at cancer each
each manifestation of cancer takes on a
different trajectory leukemia is
different than liver cancer which is
different than melanoma but they do have
one thing in common they all have
unchecked cell division so
notwithstanding all the differences of
various manifestations of cancers we
could find something that is common
across all of them the same principle
applies with these idea pathogens while
they manifest themselves in different
ways
what is common to them and hence this
will answer your question what is common
to them is that
they start with some noble cause
which then
be
metamorphosizes into nonsense in the
service of that noble cause right so for
example
if i am a militant feminist
i start off with the cause there should
be equality of the sexes which makes
perfect sense in terms of equality under
the law
but then
i say
in the pursuit of that noble goal i must
create a worldview that says that men
and women are indistinguishable from
each other because in promulgating that
message it will hopefully allow me to
better fight the sexist patriarchal
status quo so it's a form of
consequentialist ethics which basically
says it's okay to distort and murder the
truth in the service and the
consequences of a noble goal so whether
the noble goal is to make a group feel
better make an individual feel better
it's okay to rape and murder truth in
the pursuit of that noble lie and of
course i argue that i could chew gum and
walk at the same time i could be totally
supportive of noble justice uh social
justice goals while never ceding a
millimeter of the truth
but god surely
we're we're talking you know about the
truth but doesn't morality also come
into play and how the fact that
what we perceive to be good in one
society might not perceive be perceived
to be good in another
is there such a thing as universal truth
maybe with science but with other things
maybe not
well uh i think it's a universal truth
that it's not a good idea to cut off the
clitorises of little girls
that's a universal truth
regrettably if you've been parasitized
by the idea pathogen of cultural and
moral relativism
the statement that i just said becomes a
contentious one
because who are you to judge the unique
and exotic moral framework of other
cultures you discussed in cultural
imperialist right so there look in for
most things in life there are certain
global phenomena that are true across
the world and there are local phenomena
that are uh contingent on you know
culture specific contingencies so let me
give you an example
uh from from my you know evolutionary
work uh it is a universal truth that
humans have evolved the
uh taste buds the custardy preferences
to prefer
high
caloric foods over you know
raw celery so
most humans prefer a juicy steak or a
chocolate mousse to raw celery that's a
universal truth
on the other hand how much spices we use
in different cuisines
is locally determined and as a matter of
fact it is locally determined based on
an evolutionary principle the more
hot weather a culture is in
the more spice use you have in that
culture because cuisine turns out to be
a cultural adaptation to a biological
problem the biological problem is
cultures where that are in hotter
climates are more likely to have
food-borne pathogens and that
proliferate more quickly therefore the
use of spice becomes an adaptive
evolutionary solution to a local
environment so yes there are moral
edicts that might be
more or less specific to a cultural
setting but to argue that there are no
universal principles that transcend all
cultures is the height of imbecility for
example
incest avoidance is a universal taboo
right there are no cultures that say hey
mommies please when as soon as your son
becomes of a sexually mature age start
having massive carnal sex with him
that's a wonderful way to organize
society so the idea that everything is
culturally relative is just nonsensical
i was gonna say you've clearly never
been to wales gad but
but that's well we've lost all our welsh
viewers all three of them now excellent
um
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
case why is it these pathogens are so
attractive why is it that you have so
many people not only digesting them or
ingesting them i should say but also
regurgitating and why are they so
virulent well because most people are
cognitive misers meaning that they don't
put in the hard work to think and
therefore it becomes a lot more alluring
to succumb to my emotional system so one
of the things that i talk about in
chapter two of the parasitic mind is the
distinction between thinking versus
feeling now i make a a a very important
distinction here
namely that the dichotomy is actually a
false one it's not that we are a
reasoning animal or a thinking animal we
are both
the challenge is to know when to
activate which system so when for
example i am taking a shortcut
down a dark alley to get home more
quickly and i see four young men
loitering around yes and i said men
because i recognize that there's a
statistical regularity for young men to
be more dangerous than elderly female
nuns
and that's not ageist or sexist it's
called having a brain it's an honest is
what it is it's honest exactly
so in that case when i'm taking the
shortcut
and i see those young sinister looking
young men i will have a fear-based
response my heart rate will start going
up uh my blood pressure will go up it's
a emotional response but that's
perfectly adaptive
on the other hand if i'm trying to solve
a calculus problem and i activate my
emotional system rather than my
cognitive system i'm probably not going
to do very well on that calculus exam so
the challenge is to make sure that you
activate the right system at the right
time therein lies the problem so to
answer your question francis the reason
why those people are succumbing to those
idea pathogens is because those idea
pathogens take over our emotional system
right so for example
it is really empathetic and truly john
lennon uh imagined kumbaya to say isn't
it racist to have
closed borders shouldn't the lovely
hundred thousand hondurans who are
looking for a better world
be allowed to come in and benefit from
the ma you know the the magic of a
western uh first world developed economy
well i mean yes also it's it's it's bad
that
some children are
starving in rwanda but i've also evolved
the
discriminatory mechanism that says i
have to invest in my children more so
than random children around the world
right the word right so therefore i am
logical i recognize that while it is
tragic that other children are suffering
it makes perfect adaptive sense that i
spend my efforts investing in my own
children right
well progressives don't have that
nuanced thinking it is empathetic to
allow all people open borders is empathy
closed border is himmler
so it's a form of
kindergarten thinking
evan syeth wrote a book on how liberals
are engaging in a form of kindergarten
logic why because
young children go through cognitive
developmental stages where early in
their development they're unable to
engage in nuanced thinking and then it's
they grow up and they see the world in
the shades of grey that the world
existed well they feel good platitudes
of the idea pathogens and why they are
alluring as you asked francis is because
it
it feels good i like the idea that my
son could be the next lionel messi or
the next albert einstein i don't like
the idea
that michael jordan might have been born
with an a priory advantage over my kids
so social constructivism is hopeful it
triggers my emotional system as a parent
therefore i will buy into that rather
than the
the shackles of reality which is a form
of nazism
uh gary you talk about the shackles of
reality i think we unshackled ourselves
extensively over the past 18 months
since we last spoke to you uh pre the
pandemic pre-the death of george floyd
pre the blm uh protests that happened
etc so now that we've recapped uh some
of your key
themes of the book talk to us about the
real world what have you seen over the
last 18 months that has really made you
pause have you seen improvements have
you seen deterioration just give us a
kind of overall uh view of sure look
generally speaking the idea pathogens
continue to proliferate at an alarmingly
fast rate so in that sense it's not good
the news is that it's not i don't i'm
not here to be the purveyor of good news
but let me be optimistic by then
stating
that
there is a slow
uh
fight back against some of this nonsense
so if you look for example at what's
happening in the united states with a
lot of the parents who are showing
righteous indignation
against all of the nonsense that their
kids are being taught
six months ago eight months ago this
wasn't happening so someone like
christopher ruffo i'm not sure if you
guys do you know who that is we've had
him on the show recently oh wonderful
great guy he's also been on my show
uh you know
it fell into his lap right he he hadn't
planned on being the you know the
anti-crt crusader that he's become but
some people sent him some uh you know
confidential information and then he was
off and running and now he's doing great
work trying to empower people to fight
back so i think that you know while the
while certainly at the institutional
levels the idea pathogens have not yet
been extinguished i think it'll take a
while for that to happen you are
starting to see organized you know
fighting back against some of these idea
pathogens so i think
while we are still in the throes of a
deep you know culture war deep you know
ideological divide deep battle of ideas
uh i as i always say and as i you know
mentioned in chapter eight of the
parasitic mind people have to activate
their inner honey badger they have to be
ideologically fierce you know they have
to stand their ground uh when they're
fighting for their rights when they're
fighting for truth and if they do that i
truly think that if you have me on again
in a few months uh then hopefully we'll
have even more optimism to share but god
why was it so when
to me the the turning point came
when george floyd was murdered
that video was sent around the world now
obviously it's a shocking video and it's
vile and it's all indeed the policeman's
actions were completely indefensible
but why is it that had such an enormous
impact not just in america which is
understandable but in canada in the uk
all around the world we had it in our
country where our police aren't even
armed the vast majority of them anyway
look uh humans are prone to episodic
memory right so for example if i were to
ask you
uh
where were you when you heard
of 911
pretty much everyone who was old enough
to actually remember a memory would be
able to exactly tell you and that's
known as an episodic memory right it
really becomes so uh
of course people can say where were you
when you heard that jfk was assassinated
well none of us in this room was born at
that point but someone who's old enough
could say oh i remember exactly where i
was and i could tell you where i was
with 9 11 happen exactly i mean almost
to the t
in some cases you might remember
episodic memory of when you first heard
a song that has become your all-time
favorite song or how you met your spouse
well the george floyd
video is so grotesque
it is it becomes an episodic memory that
all of us can exactly remember what we
were thinking what we were doing when we
saw it the problem though
comes in when again the emotional system
hijacks our capacity to think
yes it's a very powerful image
yes it's one that will become part of
the indentable nature of my long-term
memory to think back of this grotesque
snuffing out of a human life in front of
your eyes
but then
i'm not a kindergartener i'm able to say
is this an endemic story is this what's
happening across the united states every
day right well if i have a functioning
brain if i can look at data i could
separate the horrors of that imagery
from the eventual narrative that happens
most people being cognitive misers
can't therefore when lebron james says i
am afraid to leave my house in malibu to
go to staples centers to play with the
la lakers because the police are hunting
me down and it's you know
i always feel ashamed at the horrors of
what i went through in the lebanese
civil war when i escaped execution in
comparison to the horrors that lebron
james is facing and he's got to take his
own life in his hands to take that
incredibly dangerous road from malibu to
staples imagine what a whiny pig i am to
complain about what we went through in
lebanon compared to the genocide
that lebron is facing every day
so that's why the george floyd becomes
so powerful
because you take a truly grotesque
episodic memory and you then
in a incredibly silly way
generalize it to a existential zeitgeist
well it isn't true there is no genocide
that's happening in the united states of
i hate the term people of color
that's simply not true
but yet
it triggers my emotional system i get
enraged hashtag blm down down white
police
and got another area where you talked
about you know the erosion of truth and
the replacement with things that make us
feel good and an area of specialization
for you personally
is gender and toys and and there was a
law recently in california sticking very
much with california um you know on this
very subject tell us more about that uh
please
well yeah thank you for asking uh
one of the things in my scientific
career is well the main the the main
goal of my scientific career has been to
try to darwinize
the business school the idea being that
you can't study organizational behavior
and economic behavior and consumer
behavior which is you know my main area
of interest without understanding the
biological drivers of what makes us
consumers and employers and employees
like we don't suddenly stop being
biological beings when we put on those
hats
we are what we are because of our
biology
well so one of the things that long ago
perhaps prophetically i had decided to
do was to
build what i call a nomological network
of cumulative evidence and i discussed
this indeed the whole chapter seven of
the parasitic mind is dedicated to this
epistemological tool a neurological
network of cumulative evidence is a
means by which you build distinct lines
of evidence
that point to a position that you're
trying to defend and one of the examples
that i have used in my scientific work
and that i discuss in that chapter
is the sex specificity of toy
preferences the idea that contrary to
what social constructivists say
it's not true that little johnny is
simply
taught to prefer the blue truck while
little linda is taught to prefer the
pink doll because of the patriarchy
but rather there are indelible reasons
why
these sex specific toy preferences exist
now let me give you i won't give you the
full homological network but i'll give
you a few lines of evidence that
demonstrate how incontestable the
evidence is and then i'll link it to the
to the law that brainless gavin newsom
has come out with okay so
i can show you data from developmental
psychology
you take children
who are too young to be socialized so by
definition you're ruling out the
socialization argument
and i could show you that they already
exhibit the sex specific toy preferences
little boys will tend to
point to or try to reach or look at
longer because you can't ask them
through words right they're not yet they
don't have the capacity for language yet
so developmental psychology has already
demonstrated the
uh
has ruled out the socialization argument
so if i had only shown you that data
that already destroys the social
constructivist argument but when i'm
building a neurological network of
cumulative evidence i won't stop there
i'm going to drown you in a tsunami of
evidence so let's look at a second line
of evidence i'll do a few i won't do the
whole network
but hopefully it will become evident how
powerful the methodology is
i could show you data across
animals so i can bring you data from
vervet monkeys from recess monkeys from
chimpanzees to show you that they
exhibit the same sex specificity of toy
preferences so now i've gotten new data
from developmental psychology i've
gotten you data from comparative
psychology comparative in the sense that
you're comparing across species i can
now get you data from pediatric
endocrinology so i can get you data from
in medicine you have a condition called
congenital adrenal hyperplasia this is
when little girls who suffer from this
condition have
masculinized behaviors well little girls
who suffer from this disorder what do
you think happens to their toy
preferences they're perfectly reversed
they become like those of boys okay so
now i've given you data from
developmental psychology from
comparative psychology from pediatric
endocrinology i'll do one more although
i could have spent another 30 minutes
giving you more data i can bring you
data from across cultures in cultures
that are radically different than
western cultures and show you that they
exhibit the same patterns i could get
you data from 2 500 years ago in ancient
greece
showing you that in funerary monuments
little boys and little girls are
depicted playing with the same sex
specific toys as we have today so i'm
getting you cross-cultural data
cross-temporal data cross-discipline
data all of which point to the same
ultimate fact boys and girls have
different toy preferences so now that
i've done all that
here comes the walk crusader who says
screw human nature screw science
remember the democrats are the science
party well i just gave you irrefutable 2
500 years worth of science across every
imaginable discipline that boys and
girls have different toy preferences
gavin newsom says no
social constructivism is the rigor
therefore there shouldn't be sex
differences when it comes to toy
preferences therefore i will mandate
into law
that which is inscribed in human nature
hey retailers you better not adhere to
science and you better have
gender-neutral toys
let me give you another example of folks
who denied human nature
they're called communists
e.o wilson the famous evolutionary
biologist who is a entomologist who
studies social ants
here's what he said regarding communism
he said wonderful idea wrong species
meaning communism is a wonderful idea
for social ants because social ants it
is an indentable part of their nature to
be non-hierarchical every worker ant is
the same except one reproductive queen
therefore communism works wonders for
social hands it doesn't work for a
species called humans because we are not
worker ants some of us work harder some
of us are dumber some of us are taller
some of us are leonel messi therefore
when you impose a socio-political
economic system that is contrary to
human nature you will have a hundred
different instantiations of trying the
experiment of communism and it fails
because it is contrary to human nature
so
woke laws like that of gavin newsom is a
perfect manifestation of what happens
when you deny human nature
god i'm on fire today
[Laughter]
and modest as well
i'm falling in love with myself as i
hear myself speaking
you don't get it this is called full
egotism i am joking anyways go ahead
it's fine guys they got they get that
from me every day so they they recognize
it instantly don't worry
but it seems to me
a lot of these people what they want is
a utopia
they want to be able to achieve this
promised land where
if you have communism you're going to
eradicate poverty you're going to
eradicate
a whole multitude of sins that we have
that we have in the west
if we
follow blm we're going to eradicate
racism
that to me is the core of it that they
want this utopia but unfortunately like
all utopias we're never going to get
there right well well that's exactly
right because again i remember i
mentioned earlier i said you know each
of these idea pathogens free us from the
pesky shackles of reality right utopian
aspirations are exactly that i don't
like
the pesky cruel world therefore i will
erect
edifices of [ __ ]
that ultimately feel good it's a form of
it's a it's a form of ideological
dopamine right it feels good to think
that there is a way that we can
reorganize societies where we all walk
with fig leaves around our genitalia
there's no sexual violence there is no
racism there is no poverty there is no
inequality and i think i've got the
magic pill for that it's called
communism it's called socialism it's
called blm but of course each of these
ideological movements are not grounded
in reality right lysenko-ism as i
explained briefly in
the parasitic mind
lysenko was a geneticist who disagreed
with this pesky thing called mendelian
inheritance one of the fundamental laws
of genetics right because those laws
were somehow in his twisted mind not
consistent with marxism therefore he
argued that true genetics should be more
in line you know with whatever
lamarckian inheritance which is a
discredit form of
you know genetic heritage hereditary
mechanisms therefore
science be damned
it has to be
consistent with my ideological
foundational building blocks so if
marxism is it and if 20 30 million
peoples have to subsequently succumb
into soviet unions because of my quack
theories of genetics so be it but at
least i have maintained the integrity of
my marxist doctrines so you know you
would think that scientists are somehow
inoculated from these idea pathogens and
these parasitic ideas but the reality is
they're the ones who
spawn those idea pathogens right
and that's why i'm you know while i am
very a very affable guy in my day-to-day
life you also see me when i intervene
publicly oftentimes i'm indignant
because i genuinely feel
epistemologically aggrieved when i see
colleagues of mine who should be the
navy seals of reason
being the ones who promulgate all this
[ __ ] which basically shows you you
can have all the fancy degrees on your
walls
that doesn't mean that you'll be
inoculated against all the [ __ ] and
how much of this is people responding to
an incentive structure gad whereby you
know if you say the right things you'll
be you'll be seen to be moral you'll
have more opportunities to progress
you'll have more opportunities to write
books
how much of that is just an incentive
structure that people are given and
really can you blame people for
responding to an incentive structure yes
uh i can blame them uh although i
understand that
not all people will be driven by the
same uh pure life ideas that i have in
chapter one of the parasitic mind i
basically argue that my two driving
ideals that shape my life are freedom
and truth and and i and i use these
concepts not just for the standard or
scientific truths although of course i
do mean it in that sense and i don't
just mean freedom in the sense of
freedom of speech and academic freedom i
give the example that
when i was a soccer player a competitive
soccer player i played the number 10
position where i float around as a
playmaker that freedom to create was
very important to me when a coach would
tell me today you're playing more on the
left side of midfield and you got to
track back to cover this guy it's not
because i'm a diva who doesn't want to
take instructions but the fact that you
are now
restricting my movements on the field
it was like decapitating me because i
needed the freedom to create right so my
ideals are freedom and truth those are
the fundamental drivers of my life
therefore i will never see i mean to a
fault i even talk in the book about the
fact how my exacting personal conduct to
always adhere to this punishing code of
purity sometimes has gotten me into
trouble had i been more of a careerist
had had i been more of a you know play
along to get along kind of guy i would
have been invited more to the cool kids
party but
then i wouldn't have been true to myself
meaning
the the the harshest judge of god sad is
not
the blue haired person on twitter the
harshest critic of god sad is god sad so
when i put my head on the pillow at
night to sleep
the only way i can fight insomnia is to
know that i have done everything that i
can to be an authentic person to be a
real person and therefore i never
modulate
an ounce of my dignity of my integrity
for consequentialist reasons now i
understand that that may be a rare
quality but i'm probably not the first
to say that the one who leaves who leads
an honest life is the one who truly
leads a happy life which by the way is
what i'm talking about in my next book
so no i do blame them i do look at those
people with disdain i understand that
there are careerist pragmatic realities
but then you're an [ __ ] you're a
you're a false person you're a fake
right there is nothing more beautiful
than to be authentic because you are
authentic to yourself and to others i
don't have to modulate any lies because
everything that i say comes from a place
of authenticity now that doesn't mean
that i'm always right sometimes you
might prove me wrong but because i'm
authentic i will say hey you know what
francis you know what constantine you
were right i was an [ __ ] i was wrong
and thank you for correcting me so i
always present an authentic self and all
those people who are modulating
themselves are fraudsters
the small f sometimes with a big f be
authentic be truthful that's the way to
live life well it's a great message
garen we were chatting before we started
the show about our journey from
comedians to doing this and we've
certainly found the same thing when when
you do things that you genuinely believe
in and when you don't self-censor and
when you say what you feel uh you may be
wrong but you you will be rewarded first
of all and also you will be rewarded
with joy and fulfillment internally as
well uh and it's a great message but i
want to take you back to what you were
talking about with communism and neo
wilson one of my favorite quotes as well
so given that though all of that is true
then
what is a
a structure of society
that is most optimized for human beings
in your opinion well it it is one that
allows for the flourishing of personal
autonomy and individual
rights and individual dignity right the
anything that denies
fundamental precepts of human nature
will fail so let me again take one of my
tangents to then bring it back home so
oftentimes in my courses let's say i'm
teaching an mba course and consumer
behavior you know at first students are
like this guy's talking evolutionary
psychology and evolutionary biology what
does this have to do with the consumer
behavior course and then i i always
bring it back home and say well look
a good marketer
is one who understands human nature if
you create products that are
antithetical to some fundamental precept
of human nature that product will
eventually fail on the market so for
example if i am a
creator of romance novels
well we know that romance novels are
almost exclusively read by women all
around the world there is no culture
where that pattern is reversed
almost exclusively read by women and
they you they read those books because
it is a form of fantasy escapism right
and so typically if you want to study
the content of romance novels one of the
things that you could do is study
what is the
typical archetype of the male hero in a
romance novel and he's always the same
guy he is tall he is a prince he's a
neurosurgeon he tackles alligators on
his six-pack and
you know causes the alligator to submit
and he could only be tamed by the love
of this one woman this lion of a man can
ultimately be reigned in by this woman i
just explained every single romance
novel that has ever been written since
the pleistocene era okay
that
exists
because romance novel writers are
targeting women right marketing is
segmentation and targeting they're
targeting women they understand the
needs of women when it comes to
purchasing that product and they adhere
to it now a company that's progressive
comes along and says we want to free
ourselves from the shackles of the
archetype of the male hero
we want to create a new genre of romance
novels where the male protagonist is
pear-shaped he's got a nasal voice he
plays video games all day in mom's
basement he sucks his thumb in a fetal
position he watches bridget jones
diaries while crying because he put on
three pounds yeah that's right i'm the
king of comedy okay so therefore
therefore we're gonna create a new jar
of romance novel that adheres to this
more gentle
non-toxic masculine male well what
happens to that jar it fails in the
marketplace because women say sorry
progressive company we're not interested
in fantasizing over this guy we're not
buying your product so then i tell my
mbsa students so do you understand why
we have to be grounded in human nature
so now you can see how i'm coming back
to your question
a good society is one that has certain
features you know
you need to make sure that there is a
police force a military there needs to
be a mechanism to ensure that people can
come into my home and take what they
covet from my home
but
a good society is not one where gavin
newsom tells
free
retailers how to organize the
merchandise layout in their stores
that's not how you should organize
society
a good society is not one where you put
the the
collective as being more important than
the individual that's communism
i am first got sad before i'm a member
of a tribe so judge me for all my
qualities and faults as an individual so
the reason why the west was such a
miraculous anomaly is because classical
liberalism recognized that it said
everything should be rooted in the ethos
of individual dignity and now
progressives are saying no no no the the
great experiment of the western
tradition has proven to be faulty let's
return to a collectivist ethos that will
ensure that we will have a society a
flourishing blossoming society like
lebanon where everything is defined
according to identity politics so
i hope that i've answered your question
you you have god but i have a challenge
for you because we just interviewed uh
well we've interviewed a number of
people who've made this point but
among them is tim stanley historian here
in the uk who's written a book about uh
tradition and one of the things we were
sort of teasing out of him is a
conversation about whether the pursuit
of freedom can become uh
self-destructive when it's taken to to
the extreme to the point where we are
now i think particularly among people of
our generation francis and i and younger
there's a feeling and you know your
fellow canadian jordan peterson i think
has become the superstar that he has
because that feeling is widely shared
that there's a crisis of meaning and
that freedom in and of itself and
personal autonomy in and of itself and
classical liberalism dare i say in and
of itself does not provide for some of
the other things that give people
meaning now i know what you're gonna say
you're gonna say well i pursued truth
and and all of that and you do and i
really respect you for that and i tried
to do the same but the other things that
give your life meaning are your children
your family your social relations your
community etc and those are not
necessarily uh benef benefiting from the
exclusive pursuit of freedom would you
not agree with that
actually it might surprise you i fully
agree with you right
it's not that
the ethos of individual dignity as
promised by the state
is inconsistent with the recognition
that humans
are a social species that humans exhibit
traits that are communal in nature right
so the fact that
i have an innate mechanism to love
my children to love my spouse
to love
my non-kin you know
i'm sitting with you guys and i
appreciate greatly what you guys are
doing and i might feel a great kinship
towards you right the kinship
implies as though we were biologically
linked even though we're not so it's not
as though evolutionists say oh it's a
you know a
brutish world each man for himself
pursue selfish interest no as a matter
of fact reciprocal altruism the
mechanism of reciprocal altruism is at
the root of understanding the
evolutionary mechanisms that create
cooperation so it's not as though an
evolutionist is unaware that
even though we pursue individual
interests these are ultimately also
rooted in the recognition that we are
social species but these are not
contradictory so i see what you're
saying god sorry to interrupt so what
you're actually against you're not
against sort of encouraging altruism
you're against compelled altruism
essentially right compelled altruism uh
i mean look what you you mentioned
earlier my buddy jordan right uh
he's not saying don't be nice to
transgender people he's saying don't
force me to say what the gender pronoun
to use so to use your word compelled
don't compel me to say something i'm
going to be kind and and and sensitive
simply because i'm kind and sensitive so
that if students were to come to me and
say you know here's my situation here's
how i say of course thank you for
telling me and i'd be happy to to
address you in any way that makes you
feel good but i don't want the
government telling me right
when jordan why god why why don't you
want the government because there'll be
people not many admittedly with our
audience but there will be some people
watching this who are going look god
what you know the government tells you
for your own sake and for the benefit of
society to to wear a mask or to take a
vaccine or to do this or to do that
isn't that you know isn't that about
safety and and that is putting the
interest of society yes it's putting it
ahead of yours but that's how we advance
the society what's wrong with the
government telling you what well
you know i hate to use a
apparently tired cliche but it exists
because it has meaning
it's a classic slippery slope argument
where does that end so let me give you
an example when i am
so i have a nine-year-old son uh you
know who uh
you know i'm sometimes amazed at the
types of conversations that we have with
one another which by the way here's a
life lesson don't don't infantilize your
children speak to them as though they
have brains right i hate people who say
oh you know they speak to you as if
you're a little puppy i speak to my son
as if he's a functioning that doesn't
mean i don't love him as a young child
but i engage his brain right he's not
some little schmuck who who doesn't have
the capacity to think why am i saying
all this we were walking back from a
cafe that i had we had gone together and
uh i was telling him about
libertarianism nine-year-old and so i
said look now we're about to cross the
street okay and again i'm gonna come to
your question i haven't forgotten what
you ask
god we have faith in you don't you don't
need all the all the apologies in
advance just go for it we believe in you
and so does our audience go for it so uh
when i'm crossing the street
uh it's a one-way street there is nobody
there there is a sign that says don't
cross there is a sign that says you've
got 10 seconds to cross
we were stopped at one point not not
during that time another time with my
wife where there was a cop standing at
the corner saying that i'm not going to
give you a ticket this time but next
time i will because you crossed when the
sign wasn't yet at zero right so what is
that cop saying and to so to speak to
your point of but what's wrong it's
safety it's the government telling you
when the government decides that the 56
year old
godzad
is incapable of engaging his faculties
and deciding and looking the one-way
street that there is clearly no car
coming and therefore he can cross but a
22 year old policewoman
will issue him a ticket for not having
waited even though there are no cars
coming
that's not libertarianism that's
overstepping the government boundaries
so
no one is questioning the fact that we
grant the government certain rights
to compel us to do certain things that
are good for the collective the question
is where do you draw the line right
that's where the debate happens i argue
that it's not for the government
what bloomberg did say in uh
when he was mayor of new york it's not
for the government to mandate whether
you should have sugary drinks or not yes
it's a stupid health choice to drink
yourself to diabetes by drinking 75 cans
of
coca-cola a day but it's not for the
government to say if you do it i will
punish you because then you don't live
in a free society then i am not an
autonomous agent who is in control of my
personal trajectory there is a better
entity out there that knows better for
me does that make sense
sure
god it seems to me when we're talking
we have a form of privilege
and i'll see if you're gonna push back
on this
we don't have western privilege because
we've seen the other side i saw it in
venezuela actually my family i have
family from lebanon so
i've seen it with their over there as
well you've seen it in lebanon
constantin has seen it in russia we've
seen the other side what happens when
society breaks down when
socialism gets introduced into a society
do you not have a certain sympathy and
an understanding for people who haven't
seen the other side of it because if you
haven't experienced this
then are you ever truly really going to
understand it
yeah well to those people i would say
crack a book
also right
but you're exactly right because i've
often argued that some of the staunchest
defenders of the western tradition
are immigrants
precisely because they have sampled from
the wide buffet of possible societies
and they know that the miracle of the
western tradition is exactly that it's a
miracle it's an anomaly the history of
humanity is not littered with
free societies individual dignity that
that's not the default structure of the
human condition so it takes people who
have
existed in the default societies that
are not congruent with the western
tradition who then come to the west see
the traditions that we have and say what
the hell are you morons doing how are
you putting all this up away without
anybody having even conquered you at the
gates you're saying that you will
self-sabotage right that's why i am
existentially
angered all the time because i simply
can't believe what's happening right
so i think your instinct francis is
exactly right
if you've seen venezuela if you've seen
the former soviet union if you've seen
lebanon then you know how beautiful
canada or britain or the u.s
historically have been and therefore you
want to fight for those values if you
were born into them and never knew
anything else you think that it is as
natural as the sun rising tomorrow it
isn't you truly have to fight for those
uh freedoms as ronald reagan famously
said that every generation you have to
re-fight against those who are trying to
uh you know eradicate freedoms
god it's been an absolute pleasure as
always it's such a joy to speak with you
we will we always end our interviews
with the final question which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
uh we should be talking more about
why had i not had the career ending
injury that i had when i was a soccer
player how i would have been
up there with messi that's the thing
that i think we should be spending a lot
more time no seriously i think it's not
so much that we we we're not talking
about all these woke idea pathogens i
think what we're not doing is
more of us
are not getting engaged in the battle of
ideas i think what upsets me the most on
a day-to-day basis is to see the the
apathy of people right you know yeah i
mean jordan peterson is talking about
this godzilla is talking about this i'm
busy with my daily life i'm busy
purchasing my groceries tonight i'm busy
preparing for my upcoming wedding i
don't have time to get into this battle
of ideas let some other folks with
bigger platforms and more of a spine
handle it for me
and that reflex is one that we have to
be talking more about so that we can
compel people to activate their inner
honey badges that we can compel people
to say yes you may not have the platform
of joe rogan but
you your voice truly does matter even
within your small sphere of influence
you can affect change if your professor
says something that is insanely contrary
to
uh reality challenge them politely if
your facebook friend says something
that's offensive don't feel threatened
that they might unfriend you if you
challenge them challenge them so i think
that's what we need to be talking more
about how can we get people
to feel empowered to speak out against
this nonsense believe me we will wake up
in 50 or 100 years and say how did this
happen and if people have a copy of this
conversation they will know how it
happened it's because of cowardice it's
because of apathy it's because of
diffusion of responsibility onto others
that these idea pathogens proliferate if
we all talk against them we will solve
the problem by next weekend
god thanks so much for coming back we
are going to do a couple of questions
for our local supporters uh but in the
meantime uh thank you for your time and
thank you all for watching and listening
at home make sure to get the parasitic
mind if most of you will have it already
but if you haven't it's a wonderful book
uh and uh we'll be back very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one or raw show all of them go out at
7pm uk time and if you want your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below